Hello and welcome, everyone! I'mJames Murphy.
And welcome to mCoding
where we try to get just a little bit
better at programming every episode.
Here's a trap that every single Python
programmerwill fall for at some point in their career.
There's pretty much no setup.
All I've got is asmall class with a
class variable "__count," a getter, and a setter.
We create an instance of
the class and print the count just as a control.
Then, instead of using our setter, we
manually reach in and try to change the count.
And then we print it.
Couldn't get much
simpler of an example than that, right?
So what do you think it'll
printwhen I run this main function?
I'd give you a minute to think about it.
But itseems like the answer should be very obvious.
The first print statement should print zero,
that's the default class variable.
And the second should print 42.
But when we actuallyrun the
code, we see zero printed both times.
But there's what, 11 lines of code here.
What could I possibly be doing wrong?
If you don't already understand what's goingon,
the frustration of a bug like this,
THIS IS OUTRAGEOUS, IT'S UNFAIR!
HOW CAN YOU BE ON THE COUNCIL
AND NOT BE A MASTER?
No, I'm not using a non-ASCII look-alike
characteror some other thing to trick your eyes.
But yes, it does have something
to dowith the name of the variable.
In particular, it has everything to
do with these two leading underscores.
If you just name the
variable 'count' insteadof '__count',
you would get the output that
you're probably expecting in the first place.
Sosomething funny is
going on with the underscores.
But if I use the setter, everything
would haveworked fine.
It was only when I tried to
directly change the object that it didn't work.
And toadd to the
confusion, the value 42 is in there.
When I directly set the value of the count,
and I print it out by directly grabbing its value,
we do see the 42.
It's just thecall to 'get_count' that still returns 0.
To figure out what's going on
let's printthe dictionary of this
object after setting the count with both methods.
Very surprisingly, ifyou're not aware of this feature,
the dictionary contains two different count variables.
Oneof them is the one that we intended to set.
And the setter apparently set this variable.
W H A T ?
And likewise, the getter
appears to be getting that weird variable,
notthe variable that we set in our code.
Well, let me introduce you to the questionable
feature behind all of this confusion:
Private Name Mangling
Basically, if you're inside a class and
you name a variable with two leading underscores,
then Python will replace all uses of that
variable with a mangled version of that variable.
The reason for doing this is
to sort ofsupport private access specifiers
like they have in other languages like C++ and Java.
Suppose I'm building a GUI
library, and I havea base widget class.
I keep count of all the widgets and
increase it whenever I create a newone.
I also use the count to give each widget a unique ID.
But there are going to be tons of
different widgets, text boxes, labels, buttons.
But in some subclass, like this
button,I might also have some kind of count.
In this case, the button's count
means somethingtotally different.
The button is counting
how many times it's been clicked.
Whereas, the countin widget was like the total
number of widgets that had been created before this button.
Butmaybe, I have a whole class hierarchy of widgets,
And I didn't write all of them.
Most of them werewritten by a
mix of ten different open-source developers.
And of course, anyone that uses
thelibrary is free to create their own widgets.
Because of this automatic private
name manglingthat happens, there's no conflict here.
All uses of this '__count' are automatically
replaced with this '_widget__count'.
Whereas, all usages of this '__count'
get replaced with '_Button_count'.
Because of the private name mangling,
theauthor of the 'Button'
class doesn't need to know or care
about the variables and private
implementation details of the widget class.
Everything just works, and there's no conflict.
At least, that's how it'ssupposed to work in theory.
But in reality, this picture
comes with alot of asterisks.
The first very important asterisk here
is that Python does not have privatevariables.
All variables in Python are public.
This private name mangling
just changes the nameof the variable.
It doesn't actually prevent anyone from accessing it.
So if you know howname mangling works,
you can still reach inside the
class and change anything that you like.
The intention of name mangling
is to prevent accidental reusing of variables,
not purposefulmodifications by
a nefarious class author.
The second asterisk is that
the rules for how namemangling works
and which variables it applies to are pretty weird.
Python does this name mangling
if your variable starts with two underscores.
Unless it also ends with two
underscores, then it's not mangled.
Including if your variable is
just two or threeunderscores.
And it does this for all
identifiers, including local variables.
So if you were tolook at the local
variables of this function, you would see this.
Including, for some reason,imports,
unless the import has a dot in the name.
And it doesn't just do
this on 'self' and localvariables.
It does it on any usage
of a variable name of this form.
And the mangling is done based
on the class where the code is defined in.
Not the class of the object.
So this statement will
try to set this '_a__version' of the x variable.
Even if b isn't an instance of a.
Because thisinit function
was defined inside of the A class.
It's going to use A here.
But itdoesn't just use the class name.
If you add underscores to the beginning
ofthe class, that doesn't change the mangling.
So, even if you have a bunch of underscores
at the beginning or, more realistically,
one underscore at the beginning, the
mangled name will still just have oneunderscore.
Unless the class name is onlyunderscores.
Then nothing is ever mangled.
.
. .
. . .
. . . .
. . . . .
. . . . . .
. . . . . . .
. . . . . . . .
. . . . . . . . .
. . . . . . . . . .
. . . . . . . . . . . . .
. . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . .
. . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . .
. . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . .
. . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . .
If you're interested, here's a Python
implementation of how the mangling wouldactually work
based on the given class name and identifier.
And if you're looking for the actual
CPython implementation,
then you're looking for this 'Py_Mangle' function.
Don't worry. I'mnot
actually going to go over the C code.
But the one thing that I do want to take
away fromthis is actually the name of the file this is in.
It's called 'compile.c'.
That's right. Asif it wasn't already confusing enough,
name mangling actually happens at compile time.
Yes,Python is compiled and it is also interpreted.
And the name mangling happens at compile time.
So that means if I have
this 'get_count' example like at the beginning,
the usage of '__count'here isn't
mangled because it's not inside the class definition.
And we see 0,just
like at the beginning of the video.
But if I had defined this
'get_count' functionoutside of the class
and then assigned it at runtime,
then because when this function
was compiled, it was not inside of a class,
this usage of 'self.__count' doesn't get mangled.
And therefore we see 21 instead of 0.
So literally just moving where the function was
defined can change the behavior.
That means in any class
depending on this private name mangling,
youcan't use many
of the dynamic features of Python,
No dynamically created
methods, metaclasses, ordecorator magic.
That's not to say those things can't work.
But it just becomes incredibly,
incredibly confusing in order to make it work.
If you want to stay safe and not worry about it,
you're pretty much
limited to features of static languages.
Which is not completely bad.
In fact,I recommend
that, especially for larger projects,
you self-impose a lot of the
restrictionsthat static languages force on you.
But that's besides the point. Just be aware.
If you're usingmangled names,
there is a very high chance that
other developers, including yourself in thefuture,
will be confused by what's going on.
In order to get a feel for when
and how Pythondoes this mangling
and to verify that it actually does
happen at compile time, not at runtime,
Ihighly recommend you check out Compiler Explorer.
For Python, It shows you the
bytecode output of your module.
You don't need to understand all the bytecode
in order to see what's going on here.
Put in a recognizable constant so you can
find where that corresponds to in the bytecode
Very nearby. Notice we have this "store_attr".
Andthere we see it, a mangled name.
You can see how if we don't
meet the requirements of a mangledname,
like just having a single
underscore, then the mangling doesn't happen.
Same thing ifwe had two
trailing underscores. No mangling.
We can use this to see that the mangling
stillhappens even if we're just using a local variable.
And we can see that it still happens
evenif we have a deeply nested dotted name.
Any use of this identifier will get
mangled as long as we're inside the class.
But if we're not inside a
class, lookfor that constant here.
Then the name doesn't get mangled.
Please try this yourself.
Check out all the different cases
of variable names and class names and whatever.
And see foryourself when
and where the mangling happens.
My favorite absolutelycursed case of this is this.
Of course, I've literally never seen an
actualmodule that's prefixed with two underscores.
But just so you can see what the compiler does.
We cansee Python does
not mangle the name of the module,
But it does store the
module under a mangled name.
But if we just import a double underscore module,
then both the stored name
and the importedname are mangled.
And I guess it's mostly just curiosity at this point.
EvenI wouldn't do something this cursed.
Now that we understand that
name mangling happensat compile time
and after a brief break to calm down,
I just wanted to address
what's usually themost common question.
And that's how does name
mangling work with 'getattr' and 'setattr'?
Mangled names are just names at runtime.
So if you want to use 'getattr' and 'setattr',
youneed to just manually mangle the name yourself.
And additionally, mangling
does not applyinside strings.
It only applies to identifiers.
So think variable names and dotted names.
Ifyou use 'getattr' or
'setattr' and forget to mangle the name,
you're probably going to
get an error or set the wrong attribute.
So finally, we need to
address the elephant in theroom.
And that is, because of the
confusion and complexity of name mangling,
do people actually
use private name mangling in practice?
And should you use
private name mangling in practice?
In myactual experience programming in Python,
I pretty much never use this.
And I pretty much never
see it in anyone else's code either.
So what do I see?
The most common thing that
I see is singleunderscore variable names.
Now, different people will tell
you that a single underscore prefixmeans that
a variable should be treated as a private variable
or a protected variable or animplementation detail.
And I'm not going to argue about the
technical definition of what it shouldbe called.
Suffice it to say that the convention
and the popular unspoken rule is that
anunderscore prefix variable means "don't touch me."
If the author of the class
meantfor you to be able to change it,
they would give you a way to do that.
Often through getters and setters.
Rarely, I do see this dunder
form of anattribute to mean private.
But actually, I more often see
that as a public kind of magicattribute.
More like a dunder-len or a dunder-str.
These are typically not private.
It's very commonand
expected for a class to override these.
But the problem is that these approaches
don'tactually solve the original issue that we had.
Remember, we had a hierarchy of widgets.
And wedidn't want someone writing a widget
to have to understand the implementation details.
And avoidthe variable
names of all the parent classes.
If I just use single
underscore prefixes on myvariables,
that's certainly clear to readers of my code that:
This is an implementation
detail. You're not supposed to touch.
But in order to know what all
thoseattributes are that I shouldn't touch,
I need to end up reading all the
source code of all my parent classes.
Otherwise, how do I know that my  parent
classdoesn't have their own 'don't-touch-me' variable?
And so you have a choice, a trade-off.
Youcould use a single underscore.
And force that every class that inherits from you
needs to knowthe implementation details of your class.
Or you could use private name mangling.
That way peoplethat want to subclass your class
don't have to worry about
any of your implementation details.
But you pay the price in
terms of using this confusing feature.
And you lose some of that
ability to use Python's dynamic capabilities.
Or, and this is also a very questionableidea,
you could manually mangle the names.
Subclasses don't have to
know about yourimplementation.
There's no unexpected, hidden, or confusing side effects.
But your codelooks
horrible, and your co-workers hate you.
Honestly, it's a trade-off
youneed to decide for yourself.
But full disclosure, in the wild, themost
common approach is to use thesingle underscore.
And to just hope subclasses
don't clobber your implementation details.
If you're very good about keeping your
classesdefined as if they were statically typed,
then you could also write a letter rule to help you.
But in any case, go forth and decide for yourself.
As always, thank you for
watching and makingit to the end.
If you enjoyed my video, please do subscribe.
And if you especially enjoyedit,
please consider becoming a patron or donor.
Thanks to all my patrons anddonors for their support.
Don't forget to slap that like
button anodd number of times.
I'll see you next time.